>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS HAVE
STOLEN YEARS OF YOUR LIFE, YEARS
THAT YOU WILL NEVER GET BACK IN
SEARCH OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THE HUNT FOR IT LEFT BROKEN
CREDIBILITY ACROSS THE BOARD,
PARTICULARLY AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THE FBI FOR EXAMPLE STARTED
SPYING ON CARTER PAGE A U.S.
CITIZEN WHO WENT TO THE
NAVAL ACADEMY AND SERVED AS A
NAVAL OFFICER BASED ON A
POLITICAL MOTIVATED, STILL
UNCORROBORATED SERIES OF
ALLEGATIONS FROM FUSION GPS
WHICH WAS AN ARM OF THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN.
NOW FUSION GPS FOUNDER GLENN
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLE
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLD
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLN
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLG
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLT
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLE
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLF
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLH
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLT
SIMPSON IS AVOIDING          PLO
AVOID TESTIFYING BEFORE
CONGRESS.
DEVIN NUNES JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
BEFORE I ASK ABOUT GLENN SIMPSON
AND WHY YOU THINK HE MIGHT NOT
BE TESTIFYING, I WANT TO GET AN
UPDATE ON THE DOCUMENTS THAT THE
REST OF US WERE SUPPOSED TO SEE,
MOST SPECIFICALLY THE FISA
WARRANT THAT ALLOWED THE SPYING
THAT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
DID ON CARTER PAGE, ARE WE EVER
GOING TO FIND OUT THE
JUSTIFICATION?
>> YEARS OF YOUR LIFE AND YOU'RE
NOT GETTING BACK, MANY AMERICANS
INCLUDING MYSELF -- I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT OPENING.
IF WE ARE VERY FRUSTRATED THAT
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET
THESE DOCUMENTS OUT.
THE PRESIDENT ORDERED THEM AND
THEN YOU HAVE ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO
GOT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
I WOULD BE FINE IF HE HAD A REAL
REASON BUT EVERY TIME HE SAID HE
HAD A REASON TO BLOCK THIS
INFORMATION, IT ENDS UP BEING
FALSE.
NOW YOU HAVE ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO
WON'T TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE THIS
INFORMATION?
I GUESS WE ARE WAITING, THE
PRESIDENT PUT THE IG IN CHARGE
OF IT -- HOROWITZ.
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS A GOOD
IDEA.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE COUNTING ON.
>> Tucker: AT SOME POINT YOU
ASK WHAT'S THE POINT OF VOTING?
YOU ELECT A NEW GUY BUT THE SAME
PEOPLE ARE IN CHARGE SUPPORTING
WHAT YOU WANT.
IT DOES CALL INTO QUESTION
DEMOCRACY ITSELF.
DO YOU THINK ANY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WOULD BE WILLING TO
TAKE THE RISK.
AS AN AMERICAN, I THINK YOU HAVE
A RIGHT TO SEE THIS.
>> THE CHALLENGE WITH THAT IS WE
CAN TALK ABOUT -- WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS ON OUR SHOW -- WE
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN H
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN E
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN U
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN F
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN O
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN R
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN A
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN D
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN S
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN A
CAN'T MARCH THE DOCUMENTS DOWN P
THEM DOWN.
THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE IN
POSSESSION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI.
THERE SHOULD BE NO REASON, WE'VE
BEEN NARROWLY FOCUSED ON 20
PAGES THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN SIGNED
AND I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE
IN THE DECISION-MAKING PROCESS
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SHOULD SEE THESE OR NOT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT
COMPLETELY.
LET ME ASK YOU TO SUM IT UP
SINCE YOU ARE PRIVY TOO MUCH
MORE INFORMATION THAN THE
AVERAGE PERSON -- HAVE YOU SEEN
AND ANSWER THIS KNOWING IN THE
END WERE GOING TO KNOW ALL THE
FACTS.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY EVIDENCE THERE
WAS COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT?
>> NO I HAVE NOT, AND IN FACT I
SEE THE OPPOSITE THAT WE KNOW
FOR SURE.
YOU'RE GOING TO ASK ME ABOUT
GLENN SIMPSON IN A SECOND AND I
HATE TO JUMP AHEAD.
GLENN SIMPSON, WAS WORKING FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
HE GOT INFORMATION FROM
RUSSIANS, THAT INFORMATION WAS
FED INTO THE FBI.
GLENN SIMPSON WAS SPREADING THAT
INFORMATION OUT TO THE PRESS AND
NOW WE KNOW GLENN SIMPSON WAS
MEETING WITH THE FBI LONG BEFORE
HE TESTIFIED TO CONGRESS THAT HE
WAS MEETING WITH THE FBI.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO LIKELY LIED
TO CONGRESS, SHOULD PROBABLY BE
PROSECUTED WHICH IS LIKELY WHY
TODAY HE PLED THE FIFTH AND
REFUSED TO TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: IT IS SO